صحيح نعم ما هذه اتاحه جديده من قبل
السعوديه عبر تطبيق نسك والذي يستطيع فيه
ممن يرغب الحج التقديم عليه حتى لو مضى
على حجه خمس سنوات ايضا بامكانه اضافه 13
مرافق مع في نفس الباقه التي يحتاجها طبعا
هذه من خدمات السعوديه التي سوف تتيح لمن
يرغب بالحج هذا العام بان يستفيد من هذه
الخدمات طبعا البوابه مفتوحه للجميع هي
لها وقت محدد حتى الخامس عشر من شوال سوف
يتم
بدء في هذا التطبيق وكذلك ايضا مستمر في
ذلك عبر الحملات الخاصه لمن يرغب ايضا
الحج سواء للمقيم داخل السعوديه وكذلك من
شركات الحج التي تعتبر من حجاج الخارج هذا
بالنسبه عن الحج طب خلينا نروح لموضوعك
برضه يتعلق بالعمره موضوع هاني مميز زم
زميلنا عديل اجا من شوي وضيف الزملاء هون
في العربيه ميه زمزم فما زمزم وملايين
المعتمرين بتحدث عن اكثر من عشره مليون
لتر تقريبا مياه زمزم شهر رمضان ماذا تقول
لنا في هذا صحيح نعم
احنا برضو للذكر قبل قليل كنتم تذكرون عن
الماء اليوم بالنسبه للانسان ولكن فما
بالك انه هذا الماء هو ماء زمزم طبعا هذه
راح نوري واحده من الحافظات او اشكال
الحافظات سواء المبرد او غير المبرد
بالنسبه لمياه زمزم اضافه الى اكثر من 600
مشربيه من المشربيات الرخاميه الفخمه ومن
السلستين حتى لا يتغير طعم ما زمزم وهي من
المياه المبرده وبرضو هناك عبوات ولمياه
زمزم في عبوات جيده وجميله ومعقمه يتم
توزيعها على صحن المطاف ولكن بما اني انا
موجود على سطح المسجد الحرام في بامكاني
استفادها من مياه زمزم من هذه الحافظات
التي يتم توزيعها عندنا اكثر من 30 الف
حافظه بهذه الشكل سواء من مياه زمزم او
غير مياه زمزم ومو انتم بالحالكم اللي في
الاستوديو تشربون مياه زمزم احنا نشرب
المياه زمزم على طول من البئر
يعني وليس فقط ماء لتروي العطش بل هي ماء
مقدسه ومباركه من الارض المقدسه صحيح جدا
طبعا اليوم كنا انه في المختبر نعم بس
بشكل سريع لها مختبرات خاصه تكشف اي نعم
في مختبرات خاصه للمياه زمزم وتكشف فيها
عن اهل الشوائب هذه حتى من اجل سلامه وصحه
المعتمرين والزوار المسجد